Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
forch.
Abu
Bakr
narrates here that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said, "If two
Muslims meet one another with their
swords, then the killer and his victim
are both in the hellfire."
Notice the wording here. If the killer
if the if two Muslims
meet one another with their swords
then both the killer and his victim are
in the hellfire.
Here the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
is saying a whole lot in this one
sentence.
The wording that he chose,
if two Muslims
because
it is of the actions of the kufur,
meaning killing a Muslim
is the sole domain of those who
disbelieve in Allah. They epitomize
this act. And for this reason
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
alkari hadith of Omar.
[Silence]
And notice what the wording is. He says,
he said to the companions,
he announced to them, "Do not go back on
your heels after my death,
after my departure.
Do not go back to kufur. Do not go back
to being disbelievers.
each of you striking the neck of the
other meaning in battle fighting with
each other. Do not go back to being
disbelievers.
He also said
that insulting a Muslim is fulfing
him is kufur is disbelief.
What's that mean? Does that mean that
the mere act of fighting a Muslim makes
a person a disbeliever?
This is the sole act of a disbeliever.
Meaning it's one of the proprietary
features of disbelief.
What is one of the most prominent
features or one of the most prominent
descriptions of a disbeliever?
One one of the things that the
disbeliever is most known for. If I were
to say who is the Muslim and we said the
Muslim is the one who
faces the of the Muslim,
the one who eats from the slaughtering
of the Muslim, the one who prays the
prayer of the Muslim. This is the
Muslim. The prophet defined the Muslim
in this in this way.
menus.
He said whoever faces our and prays our
prayer and eats from our slaughtering
then he is the Muslim. For him what is
for the Muslims and against him is what?
The Muslims. So we say that praying
is Islam. It is not all of Islam. It is
part of Islam. It's one of the most
prominent features of Islam. Correct?
Same thing with
Hajj is
does that mean that if a person just
goes stands on and that's all he does
that he is now a Hajj? No. His hajj
wouldn't be valid according to the
consensus of the scholars. However, this
is to articulate the importance of this
pillar of Haj which is standing on
same thing if we were to say
Allah says about the the
he refers to salah in the Quran as the
of not the salah of the Quran of so does
that mean that if I Don't pray I just
recite Quran at that I have made salah.
No, of course not. You have to make and
make your sujud and you have to make and
you have to correct. However, this is
its most prominent feature. So it's okay
to to refer to the entire unit by its
most prominent feature. Correct? And the
same thing goes when the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam says do not
go back to being disbelievers after me.
Fighting a Muslim is disbelief.
The mere act does not take a person out
of the fold of Islam.
And we understand that from his words
here.
If the two Muslims
meet each other with their swords, he
called them Muslims even though they're
fighting each against each other.
Correct.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala if two
factions or two sides of Muslims fight
one another. So Allah referred to them
as what? Muslims even though they're
fighting each other. This is what the
scholars of Islam refer to as
the actions of the actions of the
and so this act itself is kufur
meaning it's one of the proprietary
traits of disbelief but there's a
difference between kufur and al kufur
there's a difference between disbelief a
disbelief and the disbelief belief. So
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is saying a lot here when he says
man
[Silence]
When he says if the if two Muslims meet
each other with their swords then both
the killer and his victim are in the
hellfire. We understand from this that
what has landed them into hellfire is
the act
but not the disbelief that is in the
hearts that will cause a person to never
be able to enter paradise. Very clear.
The same, the same type of speech,
the same rhetoric is used in the Quran
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala when
economizing on words. Instead of
spelling every single thing out, he uses
as few words as possible to articulate
as much knowledge as possible. And so
this is why when we read these types of
narrations, we understand that what is
meant by disbelief here is the acts of
the disbelievers,
right? The acts of the disbelievers.
Just if a non-Muslim were to give
charity or if a non-Muslim were to make
Hajj or if a non-Muslim were to fight
against evil. These are acts of e
but that doesn't make them a what? A
mmin. There's a difference because eman
being a mman a believer this has
prerequisites. It has conditions. It has
pillars. And so some of the companions
Abbas referred to this asbu.
[Silence]
This is kufur which is the lesser of the
two types of kufur or referred to as by
others as minor kufur.
Minor kufur. Minor kufur means the acts
of the kufur. Major kufur mean this
person has left Islam. They have
departed from the fold of Islam. Now the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam said both of
them are in the hellfire.
We understand a lot that he didn't say.
What he said here was if two Muslims
meet each other with their swords then
both the killer and his victim are in
hell.
So what does that mean? What's really
being said and what's implied here is if
two Muslims meet each other with the
intention to kill one another and then
fight resulting in one of them killing
the other, both the killer and his
victim are in the hellfire. That's what
the sentence really means. That's the
full sentence. These are things that are
implied by the statement. And so what
articulated that meaning when he said
with their swords and this is an
important point which we will end with
and that is I don't know what's in the
heart of another person. I don't know
could be good could be bad could be
they're truthful could be they're lying
through their teeth I don't know the
knowledge of what is in the hearts of
men is the sole domain of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. However,
I do use evidence of what a person says
and behaves
as an evidence of what is in this
person's heart.
Right? So for instance, as we mentioned
yesterday, if we looked at the situation
of two people attacking each other with
deadly weapons, all right, the sword is
not used to, you know, , put someone
in line. It's not used as a
sportsmanlike fight or squabble. A sword
is used to take life. That's its sole
purpose. That's why it was designed. It
was designed for everything that.
similar to a handgun or a rifle, even
worse. These are instruments of death,
they have been designed from the ground
up to take life. And so if a person uses
a weapon that,
even if they claim, I didn't mean to
hurt him. I didn't mean to kill him. I
just meant to scare him, we wouldn't
accept that. Why? Because the action now
speaks it articulates what is in the
heart and what the intention is. We'll
pick this point up inshallah tomorrow
morning.